AMANDA SURYA: Well,
hello everybody.
I believe we are live.
I'm Amanda Surya.
I'm a developer relations
manager here at Google.
DANNY HERMES: And I'm
Danny Hermes.
I'm on Amanda's team.
I'm a developer programs
engineer, as many will know
who come to this hangout
every other week.
AMANDA SURYA: Sorry about the
delay a little bit today.
We were having a bit of
technical difficulties, but
now we're on.
So Danny, what are we
talking about today?
DANNY HERMES: So today, we're
going to talk about a feature
that isn't that well known, and
we didn't do a whole lot
of press about when we released
it, but it's an
additional feed called the User
Management feed, and it's
a way you can add more
authenticated users to your
accounts, whether they're
sub-accounts of an MCA or
whether they're just your own
account, and they're people
who are doing certain work.
Local only, or online only,
you can use the API to add
more users.
AMANDA SURYA: And for the
benefit of our viewers here
who may not know what
an MCA is, can you
explain what that is?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, so for
people who aren't familiar, a
multi-client account is a
special type of Merchant
Center account that doesn't
actually hold product data.
Rather, it holds accounts
that whole data.
So it's literally a parent for
all these sub-accounts.
And via the API, which we'll see
in a bit, you can actually
use the API to, within an MCA,
a create sub-accounts.
And we will actually create a
sub-account with my MCA that I
personally own.
And from there, we'll add
some users to that
sub-account as well.
But an MCA, like I said, it's
really just a parent that
holds accounts rather
than holding data--
product data.
AMANDA SURYA: Awesome.
So how about the merchant
account and the user's
relationship with-- do you
want to go into that?
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, so the Users
API, the User Management
feed can actually be used
whether or not it's a
sub-account of an MCA or not.
So if you have a lot of users
who are working on your
product data--
let's say you have a team that
does local only and a team
that does online only, and
you don't want them to be
interfering with each other's
data, then you could use the
Users API to really just give
permissions to your local
folks and permissions to your
online folks so they don't
interfere with each other.
But really, the best use case
is, like you mentioned, when
you have a multi-client account,
and maybe you're a
marketplace, and you want
to have your individual
sub-sellers have access to
their own sub-accounts.
Using the User Management
feed, you can do this
programmatically rather than
having to go into the actual
Merchant Center for every
single sub-account and,
through the interface, click
through and add users.
This is a much more
programmatic, extendable workflow.
So I have the User Management
feed document pulled up.
So I want to just share
this with some folks.
This is on our docs at
developers.google.com There's
a nice overview at the top
explaining what it does.
And then to review how someone
would add users, it's a simple
post request containing
very little data.
So it contains a title element,
and that title is
simply the email of the user
you're looking to add.
It contains a Boolean value
specifying whether this user
is an admin or not.
So that's in the sc namespace,
a namespace we're very
familiar with.
It's an alias we use for
schemas.google.c
om/structuredcontent/2009.
And then we also have
permissions.
Like I said, you can silo your
people on your team who are
dealing with online data and
dealing with local data
because you have separate
permission scopes for online
and for local.
And here we see online is set
to the value readwrite, and
local is set to the
value noaccess.
but there's a third value, which
is readonly, which is
sort of in between read, write
and noaccess, if someone can
see the data but they can't
actually tamper with the data.
So there are a lot of
options you can use.
And then, of course, with that
data, you simply make a post
request to a URI that looks
pretty familiar,
content.googleap
is.com/content/v1, and then
your account ID that they're
going to be added to, and then
slash users.
And there are similar URIs for
making updates and deletes.
It's that same URI I just
listed, but after users,
there's slash--
here, john.doe@shop.com.
But it's really just the email
address that you're looking to
update or to delete.
And then of course, you're
sending the same type of data
in that request back.
So let's get started and
actually use a client library
to actually do these things.
So let me switch the screen that
I'm sharing with you guys
in his Hangout.
AMANDA SURYA: Now, let's
backtrack a little bit, Danny.
So can you explain what's the
benefit of the client
libraries and in how many
languages we have there.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, so for those
not familiar, we have
client libraries in four
programming languages--
Python, Java, .NET, and PHP.
And this feature is currently
supported in
.NET and Python only.
But it's coming to PHP,
hopefully within the next two
weeks, maybe less.
AMANDA SURYA: You're
working on it.
DANNY HERMES: I'm
It's one of the easier APIs to
implement because, as we saw,
the spec is pretty short.
You only have permissions,
admin, and title, we've
already implemented, right?
So it's pretty easy to do.
Java, I don't have
an ETA for that.
So client libraries, in general,
allow you to abstract
away everything.
So you don't have to actually
deal with creating HTTP
requests, making sure the
headers are correct, making
sure you're doing all
that correctly.
You don't have to deal
with making the XML.
You don't have to deal with the
authentication, whether
you're using client login--
which is deprecated--
OAuth 2, or some other
Auth flow, right?
These libraries just do
all that work for you.
And we try to document them and
create samples like this
as frequently as possible so
they're more usable and also
so the APIs are more usable so
you can really worry about
your systems and your data
rather than actually
implementing an XML parser and
implementing an HTTP library.
AMANDA SURYA: So where can they
download this client library?
DANNY HERMES: So if you come
to our developer docs at
developers.googl
e.com/shopping-content, we
have a Developer Resources tab
that you can click that has an
end-to-end sample for
using the Items
feed in all four languages.
And each of those lists
the various places.
They're all hosted--
the code itself is hosted open
source on Google code hosting,
and there are various links in
those sub-pages within the
developer resources on
our documentation.
AMANDA SURYA: Awesome.
DANNY HERMES: All right.
AMANDA SURYA: Let's get to it.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah,
let's get to it.
So here, we have my Emacs buffer
open with two files,
create_subaccount.py
create_subaccount.cs.
Now, since Python is a dynamic
language, I can actually run
the text we see, whereas using
this C# file, I'd have to
compile it first.
So I don't actually have literal
C# code that would run
but just the C# code that you
would embed within your class
or within your function
that you're calling.
And this they're going
to be equivalent.
They're going to do exactly
the same thing, the
Python and the C#.
So we see at the top, we have
our imports and our using
statements-- import in
Python, using in C#.
So first, this is just for
protecting my own account
security, but I'm importing the
pickle library, because
I'm going to actually use that
to unpickle a token that I'm
going to use to sign
my request.
And to use the API, you actually
have to sign the
request to verify that the
account you're using is
actually your account.
And then from there, I'm
importing some custom classes.
So from the atom.data module,
I'm importing the Content,
Link, and Title classes.
And these are classes I'm
going to use to actually
create the content that's going
into a Managed Accounts
insert request.
So Contents for description,
Link is for a relative link
for that sub-account, and Title
is the title of the
sub-account.
And from the
gdata.contentforshopping.client
module, I'm going to import
the content for Shopping
Client class.
And that class is the client
that's making these HTTP
requests, and it's taking your
data and actually turning into
valid XML, and then, of course,
receiving the response
and letting us know
what it is.
And finally, from the
gdata.contentforshopping.data module.
It's a more specific data
module, specific only
to our GData API.
I'm importing AdultContent,
ClientAccount, InternalId, and
UsersEntry.
UsersEntry is going to be our
parent entry that's actually--
actually, I don't need
UsersEntry in this file.
I don't know why I'm
importing it.
My mistake.
I forgot to delete this line.
But the other two--
AdultContent and InternalId--
are there in order to have
additional settings set when
we're inserting this
managed account.
So on the other hand, all this
is already brought in when we
use the namespace
google.gdata.con
tentforshopping,
tentforshopping.elements,
and google.gdata.client.
Those three namespaces hold
virtually the same sort of
data for .NET client library.
The ones I just spoke about
for Python hold.
So from there, let me
scroll down a bit.
I am setting an account ID as
a constant and loading an
auth_token from a
pickled file.
So I have this file token.pkl,
and I'm opening it--
read-only opening it--
as this file object fh.
And then I'm using pickle to
load from fh and auth_token.
And on the C# side, again, I
have this variable account ID.
And I'm right away using it to
instantiate a service via the
Content for Shopping
service class.
And I'm passing in my account
ID to that class.
And I have left the code out
here, but if you'd like to go
check out our developer docs, I
explain in depth how you can
actually log in and
authenticate with
that service class.
But I'm going to be using the
token over here, which is
already authenticated.
So here, I instantiate a Content
for Shopping Client
class with the auth_token that
I've just unpickled and the
account ID that I've set as
a constant in this file.
So now I want to actually
create a sub-account.
So I have this sub-account, and
I'm just going to start
out with an empty ClientAccount
object.
First, I'll set the title.
So the title, my sub-account
is just Candy Shop.
Then I want to actually
set the description.
And that's in the
Content element.
So the description is, "The
best place for candy."
new_subaccount.content =
Content, and we pass into the
constructor for that class our
string, "The best place for
candy." Our actual account--
the merchant site-- is
going to be hosted at
candyshop.example.com.
So we create a link to that
using the atom.data.link
class, and that's going
to be rel='alternate'.
This is one of the
XML attributes.
And we just append this to
the Link attribute on our
sub-account object that
we've created.
And then finally, we use these
Custom Content for Shopping
data attributes--
AdultContent and InternalId to
say, no, there is no adult
content that's going to be
provided by this account.
And the internal ID that
we use to refer to
this account is CndShp.
This is not necessarily features
you need to use, but
these are features you can
use with your account.
So in order to actually insert
this, we'll have our shopping
client that we created.
It's authenticated,
because we already
created it with a token.
And it knows what the parent
account is, because we also
passed an account ID when
we constructed it.
So by simply calling
shopping_client.
InsertClientAccount, passing in
the new sub-account, I'll
actually be able to
insert my account.
And from the response we get--
inserted_subaccount--
we'll actually be able to get an
account ID of this account
we created.
So let me quickly spawn
a Python REPL.
This is one of the other great
features of Emacs that I love.
And I can actually directly run
my code within Emacs from
this buffer.
So I'm going to just call this
command to run the code, and
now we send our request
off to the server.
And there we go.
We got the response back and the
actual ID link that's in
the inserted sub-account
we got back.
It's content.googleap
is.com/content/v1.
It has our parent account ID you
see there right, 8403459.
Then slash manage accounts,
then slash 8825929.
And this is something we're
going to be using going
forward to actually create
users for sub-accounts.
So let me just paste this
right here so I
can use it in a bit.
But before we move on to
actually using the User
Management feed, let me just
show what this would have
looked like in C#.
So switching back to the C#
buffer from my Python buffer
we see it looks pretty
much the same.
We have a managed accounts entry
that's pretty much the
same as the Client Account
class in Python.
We start off with a new
sub-account, which is an empty
managed accounts entry.
We set the title via
the Title.Text
attribute on the object.
Title is actually a getter,
which automatically does this
class conversion that we did
explicitly in Python.
But here, we just give
the string, and this
library does the rest.
Similarly, for the description,
we use the
Content.Content attribute.
For link, we have an
AtomLink object.
AtomLink google.gdata.client
namespace.
And to insert it with our
service after we've added the
various other attributes, we
simply call the Insert Managed
Account method and pass
in our sub-account.
And we will expect the same type
of results, and from the
ID, we'll expect the same value
that we saw before.
AMANDA SURYA: That's pretty
straightforward.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, pretty
So now that we have
a sub-account--
the Candy Shop--
we want to actually add a
user to the Candy Shop.
And so I'm going to use the
actual account that I had for
Google I/O to actually add
this to the sub-account.
So let's see if this works.
So we're going to pull
up two new buffers,
create_user_entry.cs--
let me get this in my
clipboard first--
and then, of course,
create_user_entry.py.
So I have here,
TYPE-SUBACCOUNT-HERE so I'm
going to type the sub-account
that we've now created so when
the code runs, it actually
won't break.
So at the top, we again
have pickle.
We're importing pickle for the
same reasons, for a token.
We're again importing the
Title attribute, again
importing the Content for
Shopping Client attribute.
We're importing some
new data classes.
Admin and Permission are data
classes specific to the User
Management feed.
Admin, as we saw before,
specifies whether or not this
particular user is an admin.
And then Permission is a way
we can set online and local
permission scopes.
And then, of course, we actually
mean to import
UsersEntry here.
UsersEntry is the class which
will hold all this data.
So with that, we have our parent
ID, which is what we're
actually going to do--
I guess I don't necessarily
need this here.
I'm using it in the constructor
for the client,
but it's actually going to be
overridden in every request.
So you actually don't explicitly
need to construct a
client with an account ID,
because for every individual
API request that you're making--
like we saw before,
Insert Client Account--
you can actually pass in an
optional keyword argument that
gives an account ID.
And that's what we're going to
do here when we're dealing
with these users entries,
because we don't want to
create a user on our MCA.
We want to create a user
for the Candy Shop.
So again, I'm loading the pickle
token, and again, I'm
instantiating the client.
So from there, to create the
actual entry, I start off with
an empty UsersEntry object.
I set the title.
The title is going to be the
email, as we saw in the actual
spec, in the documentation.
So this is an email address
for my demo account.
We don't want it
to be an admin.
We don't want special privileges
given for this.
We just want them to
be able to actually
deal with their data.
And for the online permission,
we instantiate an object from
the permission class.
We give it the value readwrite,
and then we use the
keyword argument scope and pass
that the value online.
Now, we use a keyword argument
here, because the gdata Python
library considers keyword
arguments to correspond to XML
attributes rather than an XML
value or an XML element.
So if we want to specify
the attributes, we
use a keyword argument.
So similarly for the local
permission, we also set
readwrite, but instead, we have
the scope set to local.
And to add those to the entry
we've created, we simply
append pain to the
entry.permission attribute the
permission objects
we just created.
So now, if we want to actually
insert this, we simply call
the Insert Users Entry method on
the Shopping client object.
And we pass in the entry
we just created.
And like I said before, since we
don't want to actually add
this user to our MCA, we include
account ID equals new
sub-account ID, and it will be
set on the sub-account rather
than on our account.
So after we do this, we're going
to print out the ID from
the actual returned objects.
So again, we'll go back
to our Python REPL,
and we'll run this.
So let's see what happens.
Ah, so I was worried
that would happen.
So the issue here is that that
sub-account is already
associated with another account,
and we're not allowed
to actually set it on more
than one account.
So let me instead use
Amanda's account.
Amanda S, google.com.
OK, so let's run it on somebody
who doesn't already
have an account that they're
associated with.
Wonderful.
So it works as expected.
AMANDA SURYA: Now
I have access.
DANNY HERMES: Now she has access
to the Candy Shop.
Now, let me reiterate
what just happened
there with that error.
So the account that I was
attempting to add was already
associated with another Merchant
Center account.
And it's explicitly disallowed
that an account can be
associated with more than one
Merchant Center account.
So of course, API says no, we
can't do that, because it's
already associated.
So instead, we used an account
that's not associated with any
other account.
So content.googleap
is.com/content/v1, then we
have the sub-account, ID, then
slash Users, then slash the
email that we added.
And that is what we
expect to happen.
So hypothetically speaking--
well actually, before I move on
to my hypotheticals, let me
show the equivalent code for--
AMANDA SURYA: .NET.
DANNY HERMES: For .NET.
Exactly.
Thank you, Amanda.
So again, the same rigmarole.
We start with our account
ID and the
created sub-account ID.
This is not the same value.
I didn't change it.
And again, we instantiate
a service.
If we want to have the actual
UsersEntry object, we, again,
start with an empty one.
This comes from a
namespace we've
already brought in, using.
Set the title.
And again, we have these custom
setters and getters,
Admin and Permission, which will
actually do the work for
us in converting
to the classes.
So Admin, we set to false.
And Permissions, we're
actually setting to--
Permissions is actually a
list, and we're adding
permissions as we go.
So we have this online readwrite
and local readwrite.
And then, of course, to insert
it, we simply call the Insert
User method.
So now, on to my hypothetical.
Let's say the user we just added
is interfering with the
way we're managing
this sub-account.
They're deleting things that
we've inserted, or they're
making edits that they
didn't tell us about.
Or overall, they're just sort
of creating problems for us
that we don't want
to deal with.
So rather than giving them--
AMANDA SURYA: We
kick them out.
DANNY HERMES: Well, eventually
we'll kick them out.
That will be the
second stage--
the second hypothetical stage.
But first, before we say, you
don't have any privileges at
all, we're going to just change
the permissions they
have, which is what
we can do, right?
So we're actually going
to update the users.
So rather than posting,
inserting, we're going to send
a Put, which will update.
So let me pull up
these files--
update_user_entry.py and
update_user_entry.cs.
Actually, we'll need
to-- let me see if
it's still in my clipboard.
If not, I'll need to get
the sub-account again.
No, not in my clipboard
anymore.
So I need to pull up this
other file briefly.
Sorry about this.
One moment.
So I need to get the sub-account
ID so we can
actually make operations
on it.
The client needs the sub-account
ID for when it
actually creates the URIs that
it's making requests to.
So again, the same things as
before, we don't actually need
some of the data classes that
we imported before, because
we're only changing
permissions.
So we create our client.
And using the client, the signed
client with token we
have, we are going to call the
Get Users Entry method.
And I've got to change this
email again, because the demo
email is not going
to be working.
So we're going to call Get
Users Entry on this
authenticated client with the
first argument in email.
And then we're using the keyword
argument account ID to
specify which account this
user is coming for.
And this will actually return
the UsersEntry object that we
created before.
This is one of the great things
of using this library
is it does all the work taking
the XML returned from this and
parsing it back into an object
that we understand.
AMANDA SURYA: Does all
the heavy lifting.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, it does
all the heavy lifting.
Exactly.
So once we have this entry
object, we're going to clear
the permissions.
So we're just going to set the
permission attribute to the
empty list and then recreate new
online_permission and new
local_permission objects where
we set the online_permission
to read only so you
no longer can you
actually change the objects.
And the local permission, even
worse, we say no access.
You have no more access
to local data.
AMANDA SURYA: Oh no!
DANNY HERMES: Sorry.
You were bad.
And then we add these
permissions to the entry and
simply call the Update
Users Entry method.
And this does many of the same
things, sends the same body,
et cetera, but changes
the HTTP verb
from a post to a put.
And then after that, we're going
to print the ID just to
make sure everything worked
as we expected.
So again, let me pull up my
Python REPL and run this.
OK, so there we have it.
It ran successfully.
I'm not going to talk
about the .NET code.
We've seen that already.
AMANDA SURYA: Very similar.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, we
have the same ideas.
I'll just note that the actual
method that we're calling--
Update Entry--
simply takes this insert entry
that we retrieved.
And similarly, we can retrieve
the entry by specifying the
email address and
the account ID.
But when we call up data entry,
we don't actually need
to send the account ID, because
it's actually on the
object itself as
the ID element.
So finally, as Amanda said,
there's one more hypothetical
situation that we might
be worried about.
And that's where even read-only,
somebody is using
the data incorrectly.
Maybe somebody left an
organization and they still
have access.
Or maybe somebody is just off
the product or moved onto a
different project, and the
merchant that you're managing
the account for wants
them gone, right?
So we have, obviously,
a delete function.
And that uses the HTTP
delete verb.
So that's the last
thing we'll do.
We will delete this
user entry.
So again, let me go get the
sub-account ID so we
can paste it in.
OK.
So it's the same sort
of thing as before.
We have one extra import
we haven't seen before.
And we'll see in a bit
why we do that.
But from the generic
gdata.client module, I'm going
to be importing the RequestError
class.
And this is a generic error,
which all errors inherit from
in this library.
And we're going to do that,
because after we've deleted
someone, we expect the next time
we try to retrieve them,
they're not there.
So we actually expect a
404 Not Found error.
So we're going to, after
we delete, make
sure the delete succeeded.
So again, same type of stuff
at the beginning.
It's just in here so
the code runs.
We instantiate a client
object that we can
make requests with.
We use the Get Users Entry
method with-- oh, I've got to
update that email again.
Hey, there we go.
I spelled it right
the first time--
for the first time.
AMANDA SURYA: Everybody knows
my email address.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, sorry
about that, Amanda.
So we call the Get Users Entry
method with the email and the
sub-account ID that we've
created to retrieve the entry
again after we've updated,
after we've reset the
permissions.
And then we call Delete Users
Entry, and we pass in the
entry that we've
just retrieved.
And as a keyword argument, we
pass in our account ID.
It's much of the same, right?
And rather than actually getting
a parsed UsersEntry
object back, as we got when
we called Get, Insert, and
Update, we just get
a response object.
And that response object has
certain things like the status
code, the reason, and
the payload, if
there is any payload.
For a delete there with our API,
there actually won't be
any payload.
It'll just be an empty string.
But after doing this, I'm going
to again ask the API to
retrieve this sub-account.
So again, I've got to
change the email.
I believe this is the
last time I've got
to change the email.
I was one for four on spelling
it right the first time.
So again, we'll try to
retrieve it using
get_users_entry.
And if it succeeds, we'll
say our status was 200.
But if it does not succeed,
we will catch an exception
request error.
We'll catch it, we'll save it
to the variable Exception
within the scope of the
exception, and we'll save our
status instead as the status
of that exception.
And of course, we're hoping
that we get a 404.
So the expected output
of this is that
the delete will succeed.
Actually let's add a print
statement in here to get the
status of our delete response.
So first, it'll print,
hopefully, 200.
And actually, let's also print
the reason for it.
So 200 OK is what we're going to
expect first to be printed
after the delete succeeds,
after Amanda has been
completely removed from
this sub-account.
And then for this second stage,
when we try to retrieve
it, we expect a status of 404.
So let's actually run
it, and let's see.
There's the first--
200 OK--
and the second--
404.
So there you have it.
AMANDA SURYA: I no longer
have access.
DANNY HERMES: A delete works,
and after doing all these bad
things and finally being moved
off the project, Amanda no
longer has access to the
sub-account that we had created.
So with that, it looks like we
don't have any live questions,
obviously, and no questions from
the moderator this week.
But we do have one announcement
to make.
I'll let Amanda make that
announcement, that--
AMANDA SURYA: Well, if you're
interested in doing this sort
of stuff that we do, in terms
of developer relations work,
our team is hiring.
So if you're interested, visit
developers.google.com/jobs and
check on our open positions
there and apply.
And again, thank you, Danny, for
walking us through how to
manage MCA and sub-accounts.
I think a lot of our marketplace
merchants will
benefit from this.
And again, if you have any
questions for us, we're doing
this biweekly.
So in two weeks, we're doing
another Hangout.
Or you can also visit our
forum and read the docs.
And if you have any questions,
visit a forum or
join us in two weeks.
DANNY HERMES: Yes.
We will see you all August
16 at 10:00 AM.
AMANDA SURYA: That's right.
All right, thank
you, everybody.
Bye.
DANNY HERMES: Bye.